talking about how the uh the age of
Jesus you think he's closer to 40 so I
just wrote down here how old do you
think John 857 because of John 857 when
the Jews said you are not yet 50 years
old that you've seen Abraham then
araneus and I can't get you the quote
right now but araneus says that they
received from the apostles the teaching
the tradition that Jesus was closer to
50 years old I'll find it for you right
now
now I'm sorry let me not misquote him
and says that he got a tradition from
the apostles that shows that he was yeah
closer to 50 let me show you let me let
me find it sorry because I don't want to
quote from Emory but yeah so but but as
I look for it what was it what did you
want to ask
me I just wanted to know how old you
thought he was in what year you think he
was
crucified well if he's born anywhere
from 4 to 6 BC some people think yeah
closer to 50 years old so I was right I
just don't want to misspeak four to six
years
old right I mean four to six if he was
born anywhere from 6 to 4 BC even if you
say 30 ad right let's say he was
crucified 30 ad if he's born four or 6
BC that still makes him around 34 36
right right but what if he was crucified
33 ad so if you add four to that that's
37 or if you add six that's 39
right right what if he was
crucified later than 36 in other words
he' be as the Jews thought closer to
40 so you do you hold to that in terms
of the crucifixion being later than 33 I
mean I for me not to hold to that I have
to explain John 857 then I have to
explain
arus I mean then how do I explain arus
and then John
57 right um
expain right but uh I think actually I'm
remembering now you mentioned uh that uh
I guess it was aronas thought he was
over the age of 40 between because close
to the 50 I'm gonna get you I'm getting
the tradition I'm gonna look for it some
because I think the uh if I'm
remembering correctly I think you said
his argument pretty much was that if he
was if he was under 40 why didn't they
just say you're not even 40 right close
yeah you're not even yet 40 years old
I'll get it for you right now I just
want to see where it is so so if I say
he was not you know closer to 40 meaning
if I can see how if he's closer to 40
they'll say you're not yet 50 but if
he's 30 three I don't see why they would
say you're not yet 50 years old so I
have the problem with John 857 then I
have the problem with araus so I don't
know because this is
why James White says you cannot trust
the tradition because Aras says they
received the tradition from the apostles
that he was closer to 50 so I'm gy to
find it for I'm still trying oh here it
is against Heretics book two chapter 22
so that's why so if I reject it then I
got problems because then that
weaponizes anti-catholic antio Orthodox
saying Apostolic tradition is not
reliable right right and and even the uh
as the as you said a minute ago even if
he's around 39 the People speaking don't
know his exact age so even if right so
yeah so it would make sense that they'll
say you're not even yet you know 50
years old if he's closer to
40 but if he's in his why say you're not
yet 50 some have tried to come up with
explanations but I don't know and then
arus seals the deal for me it says
chapter let's see what again chapter I'm
going to get it for you right now he
seals the deal from you with me there
yep here this is against
heresies Book 22 look guys if you want
the link let me know I'll give you the
link but besides this those very Jews
who then disputed with the Lord Jesus
Christ have most clearly indicated the
same thing for when the Lord said to
them your father Abraham
rejoiced
rejoiced to see my day and he saw it and
was glad they answered him you you are
not yet 50 years old have you seen
Abraham John 85657 now such languages
Finly applied to one who's already
passed the age of
40 see
that without having as yet reached his
50th year yet is not far from this
latter period but to the one who's only
30 years old it would unly be said you
are not yet 40 years old you see he made
that argument didn't
he you see it or no yep all right but
now watch for those who wish to convict
him of falsehood would certainly not
extend the number of years his years far
beyond the age which they see had
attained but they mentioned perod near
his real age whether they had truly
ascertained this out of the entry in the
public register or simply made a
conjectured right conjecture from what
they observed that he was above 40 years
old and that he certainly was not one of
only 30 years of age for it is
altogether unreasonable to suppose that
they were mistaken by 20
years right when they wished to prove
him younger than the times of Abraham
for what they saw that they also
expressed and he whom they beheld was
not a mere fantasm but an actual being
of Flesh and Blood he did not then want
Munch of being 50 years old in
accordance with the fact that they said
to him you're not yet 50 years old and
have you seen Abraham he did not
therefore preach only for one year nor
did he suffer in the 12th month of the
year for the period period included
between the 30th and the 50th year can
never be guarded as one year unless
indeed among their aons he's attacking
the gnostics there be so long years
assigned to those who sit in their ranks
with bius in the ploma which beings
Homer the poet too has spoken so you
caught
it see what he
said uh yeah he's uh those are good
points and and you know and the thing I
don't think uh people realize and I I
forget sometimes these people are a lot
smarter than we are so when we say stuff
like oh well they didn't know this no
they knew the scriptures way better than
us they knew the languages way better
than us so he would know
right yeah so now he wants to pit
araneus against Mary of AGA since araus
is the disciple of polycarp who learned
directly from John the
Apostle so let's ignore arus go with Mar
okay yeah okay whatever floats your boat
buddy whatever floats your boat so for
the rest of you now let me read the
paragraph before it
okay and this is what James White uses
to discredit Apostolic tradition so help
James White buddy webon I him this is
the paragraph before it
right see
it five you see it right you with me
brother because it takes a while to
answer yep all
right they however that they may
establish their false opinion regarding
that which is written to proclaim the
acceptable VI of the Lord maintain that
he preached for one year only and then
suffered in a 12 month he's talking
about the gnostics and speaking thus
they are forgetful to their own
disadvantage destroying his old work
robbing him of that age which is both
more necessary more honorable than any
other that more advanced age I mean look
during which also as a teacher he
excelled all others for how could he
have had disciples he did did not teach
how could he have taught unless he had
reached the age of a master for when he
be came to be baptized he had not yet
complet his 30th year because Luke says
around 30 but it was beginning to be
about 30 years of age for thus Luke who
has mentioned his ears has expressed it
now Jesus was as it were beginning to be
30 years old so he's going to scripture
by the way Protestants he's quoting
scripture Luke 323 John
857 when he had came to his baptism
according to these man he preached only
one year Reckoning from his baptism on
completing his 30th year he suffered
being in fact still a young man and who
had by no means attained the advanced
age now that the first stage of early
life embraced 30 years and that this
extends onwards to the 40th year where
everyone will admit but from the 40th
and 50th year a man begins to decline
towards old age which our Lord possessed
while he still fulfilled the office of a
teacher even as the gospel and all the
Elders testify you see he's Appo he's
appealing to the gospel and the elders
meaning what they taught those who are
conversing in Asia with John see what
they learned from John the disciple of
the Lord like polycarp who was arin's
Bishop affirming that John conveyed to
them that information so go ahead appeal
to Mary my friend because aren is saying
we got it from polycarp the Elder who
learned it from John so if you're now
you're going to discredit this W witness
you have
no no basis to argue for the authorship
of the Gospel some of them moreover saw
not only John but the other Apostles
also and heard the very same account
from them and bear testimony as to the
validity of this statement whom then
should we rather believe whether such
men as these or tus who never saw the
apostles and who never even in his
dreams attained to the slightest trace
of an apostle and then he goes to the
tradition that he was 50 years old and
then he quotes scripture so he qu
scripture that's not good enough he
appeals to the elders whom learned from
the apostles who taught him and they
said to him they said yeah he was closer
to 50 but that's not good
enough yeah and and another another
thing is that you know these people
aren't writing in in isolation like
they're writing in you know within the
church so if somebody says hey that's
not true we didn't get that uh from the
elders they're G to say it right yep so
that means the point is if arus is wrong
then how do you trust that he said I got
it from the elders who got it from the
apostles and then he quotes scripture to
show it John
857 so he not only says it was the
elders who told us he quot scripture
you're not yet 50 years
old so he quotes the scripture that's
not good enough right
he says that I learned this from the
elders polycarp who's trained by John
that's not good enough so brother I hope
that helps you I don't know but you have
another question arus who's closer again
if you guys missed it he's saying we got
it from the
elders
elers and they got it from the
apostles not just John but all the
apostles okay those who are conversing
in Asia with John disciple the Lord
affirming that John conveyed to them
that information and he remained among
them with these Elders up to the time of
trajin some of them over saw not only
John but the other apost also and heard
the very same account from them that
means he's either lying or they lied or
they're all
ignoramuses you got it brother let me
you is a saint of the church a holy
martyr disciple of polycarp another saan
holy martyr a disciple of and okay so
then James White is right don't appeal
to Apostolic
succession don't appeal guys if you're
going to not discredit him then how do
you know he's right about anything else
B is gonna have a field day with you in
James White this is one of James White's
arguments to show you can't trust the
so-called Apostolic tradition he laughs
at this he says there an is was
wrong that's it then James White is
Right arus says the elders taught us
this the elders who were conversent with
John taught us this and some of them
also met other Apostles and they said
the same thing John said we received it
from them and it's in John's gospel but
that's not good
enough what do you say to these people
brother you see why I'm I'm the bad cup
to people's good
cup yeah you know what you can't uh you
can't fix stupid sometimes you know
exactly
brother uh I have a another question
here if that's okay you can ask but I'll
tell you how because he buys into the
narrative that Jesus was
33 which we all have bought into but if
you actually read the gospels you can't
prove He's 33 do you guys know that you
know where the age 33 comes from can I
explain that real
quickly if you heard what ARA said I
don't think you're listening I want you
to listen
you want you to listen listen
carefully if you read Matthew Mark and
Luke Jesus's Ministry seems to last less
than a year do you guys know
that I want you to start reading Jesus's
baptism all the way to the end if you
read Matthew Mark and Luke you'll get
the impression all of these events took
only a year Aras is refuting the Gnostic
charactertics who said that Jesus
ministered only a year I just read it to
you so when how do we know Jesus didn't
Minister for more than a year because we
then read John and in John we have Jesus
cting at least three
Passover so that means now if I read
John it wasn't a year because he
Celebrate Three Passover that means it's
over three years but nowhere does John
tell you he's giving you an exhaustive
chronological list of all the years
Jesus ministered just like Matthew Mark
Luke don't tell you that from from the
time of his baptism to his crucifixion
Jesus celebrated three Passover it's
right away baptism straight to Jerusalem
he's killed seems like it happened a
year but then John comes and talks about
at least three Passover so we know it
can't be a year but he doesn't say only
three Passover so how do you get three
and a half years because you're assuming
John is giving you an entire
exhaustive
chronological detailed outline
of the ex exact extent of Jesus ministry
he doesn't say
that he just mentions three Passover but
Matthew Mark and Luke from the time of
Jesus baptism to the time he goes to
Jerusalem they don't talk about him
celebrating three Passover so should I
assume they think that Jesus ministered
for only a
year exactly in the beginning we don't
know you hit it on the nail and then
when we realize that even when you say
2020 ad or 2025 ad year of Our Lord now
we know we're off because Jesus is
actually born anywhere from six to four
years before the year signed to his
birth so we're off at least by six to
four
years
right so I just want to make sure people
understand if you want to argue arus is
wrong you now destroy your oldest
surviving reference to who wrote what
and then you're telling me that an
eyewitness to the very Bishop trained by
John and other Elders that he met who
met the apostles couldn't remember what
they told them got it wrong and misled
us man
that's hey man if you want to go that
route more power to you then know appeal
to Apostolic succession
and then on top of that he quotes John
857 you're not yet 50 years old and says
that doesn't make sense if he was in his
30s that's what arus says that only
makes sense if he was much older than in
his
30s
right you got it anyway go ahead what's
your question uh thanks Sam and I mean
you know what difference does it make if
he's 30 or 40 he died on the cross
that's what matters right exactly